every time I read about you every time
you're in the paper they say that you
went to some party you started to have a
good time right and then you took your
shirt off
you're always in the paper for taking
your shirt off what is that all about
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's very cool oh my god you say it
depends on how you look at him some
people look at say oh he got a gut but
this is a speed bump okay slow down will
you see get your old transmission - all
right now but what is it describe what
happens because we move our got left
okay so go to old I don't dance okay so
you go to club what happens how'd you
take you'll take the shirt off right
away
no depends on if the song is right what
do you have to be inspired if they put
Tupac or biggie smalls on then the shirt
comes off and the party just started
and he'll you take the shirt off and a
party like a rock star okay and it's if
it's biggie smalls or or Tupac you know
no the one of them the shirt comes off
guys give us a little biggie smalls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're very good at that it's a whole
process for you yeah
[Applause]
yeah
I just love anyone that just tuned away
from our show for a minute and tune back
in doesn't quite understand what
happened here oh they'll go somewhere
[Applause]
let's talk I'm gonna keep asking you
questions like this you have a movie out
superhero movie tell us about
superheroes superheroes coming out
that's my movie so go check it out job
it's movie about superheroes were you
into superheroes when you were a kid but
I respect all of them
you couldn't respect all of them I don't
respect spider-man he got real power
Superman got real pavo's even Batman got
a belt night good respect the incredible
hope you couldn't respect you couldn't
respect him why is this hope not a
superhero he was a drunk white dude in a
ball well hey yeah it couldn't been
black why because black people just too
sensitive mm-hmm you want to turn green
over every little thing
do you think he Hulk was oversensitive
and if he was black he would have been
right nice Batman what was today's
number one far-far I don't know what's
weirder what you just said or the fact
that you were getting dressed as you
said it
you